IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Hi everyone.
I'm Ibrahim Ulukaya
from YouTube
developer relations team.
And today, we'll talk about
YouTube subscribe button.
And joining me, Kurt Wilms
from YouTube product
experience, joining me today
from the Paris office.
Hi Kurt, how are you?
KURT WILMS: Hi, thanks
for having me.
I'm doing good.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Great.
So as you guys maybe already
figured out, we recently
launched the YouTube
subscribe button.
And Kurt is the product
manager.
And he will actually tell
us a little bit
about it more in detail.
So maybe let's get started.
So what is the YouTube
subscribe button?
And what is the motivation
behind this button?
KURT WILMS: So the subscribe
button is something we've had
on the desktop site
for a long time.
Clicking the button on the
desktop site allows you to
connect with the creator
behind the video.
But what we launched recently is
the ability for creators to
embed the same subscribe
button that you find on
YouTube.com actually on their
own site, so on a
third party web app.
So the motivation is
pretty simple.
There's a lot of creators
who have a
presence off of YouTube.
And we wanted to give those
folks away for their fans, for
their followers, to subscribe
to their channel directly on
their property.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Sounds good.
But how is it different than
the subscribe button on the
YouTube website already?
KURT WILMS: So previously there
was never a way directly
to subscribe to a channel
on a third party site.
So what we've tried to do is
emulate the button in every
way we can.
So it's very similar to how it
is on YouTube.com itself.
We give them a couple additional
options to
developers for the third party
button, where they can change
the style and the color to make
it integrate well into
their property.
But otherwise, it behaves just
like the button behaves on
YouTube.com.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Oh, that
sounds great actually.
And what are some advantages of
implementing this button actually?
KURT WILMS: So the main thing
behind this button, or the
main reason why you'd want to
put this on your side is like
I mentioned before.
You can give the folks who come
to your web property an
easy way to subscribe to your
channel without actually
leaving your site.
So prior to the launch of this
button, there was no way for
your fans, your followers to
subscribe to your channel on
your own site.
You would have to go to YouTube,
you have to sign in,
you'd have to find the button
and subscribe there.
This is sort of a way for your
fans and your followers to
connect with you directly on
your property without leaving.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: That's great.
So how can I show the develops
to start using this button?
How can they generate the
code for this button?
KURT WILMS: So we've launched
documentation which is live.
And when you go to the
documentation site, we have a
nice editor where you can go.
You can click around, you can
see how the button would
render on your page.
And we give you right there some
HTML code that you could
put on your site to
render the button.
If you're more advanced, if
you want more advanced
features, we also dive into the
details about how you can
customize this on your own.
How you can tweak the HTML and
JavaScript in various ways to
solve your use case.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Maybe actually
we can show this in a
demo right now.
So if you guys go to
developers.google.com/youtube,
and you will just click the
YouTube subscribe button here
on the left navigation.
And you will be able to see that
all the content, all the
confirmation options here.
So if you're a standard channel
or a paid channel,
you'll see the default button.
Or, you will have different
options having like a full
layout or with a [INAUDIBLE]
team.
And all you need is actually
go to the configure button
option here.
And you'll put your channel
name or your channel ID.
And as you see, there's
already a preview
on the right side.
And you can change the preview
as having the whole full
preview of the channel's image
and the channel's name.
And you can even go for
a darker layout.
And all you need to do is,
actually-- if you are a
beginner and you want to do an
easy way-- all you need to do
is copy this code and paste
it in your own HTML.
And from that, you will have
the Subscribe button.
But if you want to go further
ahead, you want to use the
dynamic rendering.
And then we will actually have
the dynamic rendering code
here, or the documentation
as well.
So that should be pretty
easy for that.
And besides this one actually,
say that you can render this
dynamically.
And what are the advantages
of rendering dynamically?
KURT WILMS: Yeah, so we've been
able-- for advanced folks
who want to render the button
dynamically and improve the
speed of their pages rendering
time, as well as
do different things.
If you want to do some custom
integrations on your site, or
you want to do some advanced
features, we enable that too.
But yeah, like you mentioned,
for the simple user just wants
to common embed the button,
we have a nice editor
to let you do that.
But the documentation discusses
about rendering the
button dynamically and doing
various different things.
So we have the whole
spectrum from
beginner to advanced user.
We support both cases.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: As you
mentioned, the subscribe
button is a great tool for
people to subscribe to your
channel without leaving
your own
website or your web property.
But which mediums the user will
see once they actually go
to your website, or could they
be using other mediums?
KURT WILMS: So once a user
actually click subscribe, the
one big advantage of that is
your channel will show up
across all of YouTube's
platforms.
So not just on the desktop
site, but our mobile
applications, on TV, on third
parties, et cetera.
So an advantage to putting the
Subscribe button on your site
is when your fans come and
they click it, now your
channel will be unlocked
on all the
platforms YouTube is on.
Not just on desktop, but
across our mobile
apps, TV, et cetera.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Wow, that's
great actually.
I hope all our actual users
start using that.
And that will add them to
all their channels.
And there will be way more
subscribers just
using that, I believe.
KURT WILMS: Yeah, it's a great
way to improve your channel,
gain more subscribers,
et cetera.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: OK.
Thanks for joining
me today Kurt.
That was great, and I'm
sure users will
start using it already.
KURT WILMS: Thank you.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And for
a last thing I want to
plug all the time.
And as a developer relations
engineer, developer relations,
we are hiring.
You can just go to
developer.google.com/jobs.
And we are hiring almost
everywhere in the world.
And you can select which
product area is
the best for you.
I hope you guys go
and check it out.
Thanks for joining
me today, guys.
Ibrahim Ulukaya from New York.